how hard is it to think independently to
think for yourself in Silicon Valley
well nobody knows the answers that
question better than James Day more
he's the Google employee who was fired
because he dared to believe his an
employer meant it when they said they
were committed to diversity the open
exchange of different views they don't
believe in that and they fired him for
it now he is suing the company Google
for discrimination but that was many
others like him remained in hiding in
Silicon Valley James they weren't joins
us today gee thanks coming up yeah
thanks a lot so it the deep irony is
that you think of San Francisco the
peninsula the bay area of Silicon Valley
as open-minded right has it do you think
it's become more of a one-party state
than it was a couple years ago yeah
definitely silk'n Valley started as just
sort of libertarian yes into many ideas
went to Burning Man all the time but now
it's really there's a groupthink and you
know we see it that many people are not
leaving Silicon Valley because of the so
since you were forced out of Google not
because you didn't perform well in your
job but because you tried to take them
seriously when they said they believed
in different views and they don't have
you talked to people who are still there
about it
yeah I've talked to a few and it seems
like it's gotten even worse where
they've doubled down on some of this
diversity rhetoric and people are even
more afraid now to speak up so if you
have even a mildly different view you're
crushed right and so you know surveys
show that about 80% of conservatives now
don't want to talk about anything at
work so I don't think anyone's ever
challenged the fact that you're
qualified for the job highly qualified a
Harvard degree do you've a job now
fortunately no I've applied to many
places but you know I think a lot of the
large companies don't want the risk and
then the small companies want to be
bought by Google so they don't want to
hire me either so Google's so powerful
you think they have a role and you're
not having a job now even six months
later more than yeah people are
definitely afraid of Google it's the
most powerful company in the world do
you think it's a good business model to
be associated with an extreme set of
political
Leif's google and as intolerance they
are is that a good way to kind of
broaden your market share definitely not
I think that they're really seeing the
pushback from you know conservatives and
freethinkers alike yeah normal people
good luck James I really wish I had
technology company I promise I would
hire you tomorrow but I'm just a talk
show host but he will get hired and
we're gonna celebrate when you do thank
you great to see you yeah thanks a lot